[Music]
hello and welcome to our event securing
your future
here at the spectator and kindly
sponsored by net wealth
i'm kate andrews economics editor here
at the spectator
when covent 19 cleared out our diaries
last year it also altered countless
retirement plans
some timelines have sped up due to an
increase in redundancies for the over
55s
others have been stretched as an
unsteady stock market took its toll on
some pension pots
so has retirement planning changed
permanently and will the pandemic demand
more flexibility out of retirement plans
joining me today to discuss all of this
and more i'm joined by martin vanderwear
business editor at the spectator and
charlotte ransom
ceo for net wealth i'm going to start by
asking both of them for some
of their comments on today's topic about
five minutes each
then i'll ask them some questions
directly we'll have a bit of a
discussion but we will be sure to leave
plenty of time to get to your questions
in the audience
uh which i will put to martin and
charlotte some have already been
submitted but you can submit
as you're watching tonight if you'd like
to ask a question to the panel
do so by writing in the text box on our
website
or by emailing events at spectator dot
co
dot uk so let's get right to it and not
waste any time
charlotte let's start with you thank you
kate
and hello everyone um as you heard i'm
chief executive of net wealth which
is a what i would call a modern wealth
manager we launched five years ago
really with the idea of combining the
best elements of
traditional wealth management and
bringing together
much more modern technology to improve
the overall service and i'm delighted to
be joining the spectator this evening
for tonight's discussion
we're here to talk about planning for
retirement amid uncertainty and the
pandemic certainly focused everyone's
mind
on personal finance in a way that
possibly hasn't ever been the case
before
this is arguably a good thing since many
of us prefer to leave financial planning
at the bottom of our to-do list when it
really
does deserve some attention the recent
events
across global markets and economies may
have been particularly worrying for
those approaching retirement
or in retirement since there's obviously
likely to be less room for maneuver
but what we've seen is that for many
investors any damage has largely been
undone and portfolios have actually
performed well since the depths
of the crisis last march and is a good
reminder i think of why
staying invested and not panicking
remains true it was warren buffett who
said the stock market is designed to
transfer money from the
active to the patient and that's
something that i i feel is definitely
the case
retirement might have taken a variety of
paths as a result of the pandemic
so for some it has become more
attractive with a focus on enjoying
children and grandchildren
and perhaps also travel once it's
allowed again we certainly now know
how much all of this stuff means to us
since it was taken away
but maybe retirement is less likely or
achievable for others
their port may not have been restored to
previous levels depending on
where it was invested and there may be
concerns about future investment returns
being insufficient to support
a long retirement or maybe there are
younger generations who are more
dependent on you now
than they were before fortunately
for those of us who do need to stay and
work for longer and we know that it will
be the case for some
work setups have just become a lot more
flexible and probably
favor older people given their home
working arrangements
are more likely to be better than they
would be for younger people
as the chief executive of a wealth
management company retirement has always
come up as a key topic for clients
whether we need to work for longer or
indeed we want to retire early
if markets are experiencing greater
volatility or for example
there are threats such as inflation or
we're in the process of planning for
intergenerational
wealth transfer all of these make a
difference when it comes to retirement
planning
and boils down to one main area that
bothers all of us
and that is affordability this is what
clients want to discuss with us and it's
also very much reflected
in some of the questions that readers
sent to us ahead of the panel
so how can investors know what's
feasible in retirement
both to support their lifestyle and also
to allow them to provide for the next
generation
or to fulfill philanthropic goals for
example
this question becomes all the more
poignant when thinking about future
market returns
and the potential for them to be lower
than they have been previously
and therefore potentially less able to
support a long-term retirement plan
but it's important not to forget we are
talking long
term so there was a questionnaire that
was asked of today's listeners
and 70 of you are 65 or younger
and another 20 percent are between 65
and 75
it's critical to remember that you're
planning over a long period
both in the accumulation phase and also
so accumulation phase during our working
lives and then also
during the drawdown phase and given the
length of time we're talking about
periods of market uncertainty and
volatility
absolutely should be expected but
remember they can also be tolerated
over the course of a decade or multiple
decades
one thing's for sure though we know from
many different sources that a big chunk
of the working population
is focused on this question of when and
if they can afford to retire
and it's great to be discussing the
subject with you this evening
thank you so much charlotte martin over
to you
thank you very much indeed very nice to
be with you this evening
nice to be doing this with with
charlotte ransom
um i'm the business editor
long-time columnist in the spectator and
um when kate
asked me to participate in this i said
well
you do realize that i am of an age that
i really probably ought to
be retired i'm in receipt of a state
pension and so looking at this from
that end of the telescope as it were um
and she said that's okay martin you can
speak from
lived experience i'll take that as a
compliment
and tell you that for example
um if you had met me 30 35 years ago
i was working for a bank i thought i
would probably work
for the same employer for the rest of my
working life which would last probably
until i was
60 when i would retire on a defined
benefit pension that would comfortably
look after me for the rest of my life
well
all of my circumstances changed at some
point
all of everyone's circumstances are
likely to change more so now than
for that generation um of long-term
employment with one company and so on
many things you know that happen then
are not going to happen again
so where does that take me in beginning
to think about this what i think is
retirement has to be addressed in a sort
of holistic
framework approach that is to say
whether you're in your
30s 40s approaching your 60s now
you have to ask yourself a set of first
questions really
how long do you want to work do you want
to do something else you want to travel
would you rather work you know as long
as you're physically fit to work how is
your
health then what assets do you already
have if you own a house that's
tremendously important if you own
you know more than one piece of real
property that's
that's an important part of your asset
portfolio do you have any pension
entitlements from past employments that
are
already part of the formula what
obligations do you have you have
obligations to your
offspring that you have to consider the
intergenerational question you may have
obligations to your parents people live
a very long time now you may
need to fund care for an elderly
parent long into your own early old age
and so on
so your aspirations your obligations
um all of these things have to be
considered
and a vital aspect to anything about
retirement planning has to do with tax
so there are
a number of tax advantage things you
should be doing
whether that's stakeholder pension
whether it's building up a nicer
portfolio
but what i would suggest to you is that
building up all the tax advantages you
can have
from the point at which you're able to
start saving
is by far the most important aspect of
your
saving plan and in a way it's a lot more
important than investment performance
now i'm
speaking in the company of a
distinguished wealth manager who can
talk about
investment performance i know but what i
would say is in this hierarchy of issues
you have to consider
actually how your funds perform against
the markets and so on
it's interesting but it's not the
crucial thing the crucial thing is
know what your expenses are likely to be
know what your aspirations
for when you're going to stop working
what you'd like to do for the rest of
your life and so on
know what your obligations are to your
family
and all of that and plan the whole
framework and then within that
actually the the performance of the
investments is another topic
but it's not the top of the agenda i'll
pause there
well thank you so much martin and
charlotte um
martin we're delighted that you are with
us tonight so thanks for being here um
i'm gonna jump right into you
questions um some uh pre-planned um
that have been submitted from the
audience um others that i have for the
two of you and then
we'll go to some of the live questions
that are already coming in
and just a reminder to our audience if
you do want to submit a question while
you're watching tonight especially
something that martin charlotte has said
has sparked your interest
you can do so through the text box on
our website or you can email events at
spectator dot co
dot uk um so charlotte it's impossible
to speak about
pensions and retirement and savings now
without
um paying some kind of acknowledgement
to the pandemic and
i have some figures in front of me and
december last year
13 of over 55s said that they were
expecting to delay their retirement due
to the coven 19 crisis and 52 percent
of all uk adults said they were
concerned that the crisis meant
that they would not be able to afford
the current lifestyle or the lifestyle
that they aspired to in retirement
so how has the pandemic changed how
people are broadly thinking and feeling
for retirement
and their financial health more
generally
yes thanks kate i mean as i mentioned in
the introduction the main question that
keeps coming up and it's really what
you're talking about is just how
affordable is retiring now or in the
future
and i would definitely extend this to
overall financial health
the combination of really volatile
markets
high asset prices and the potential for
inflation are all ingredients that focus
the mind
but actually many factors remain the
same as they always have been when
working out this
key question around affordability and
to do this you need to put together what
i think of as a sort of personal balance
sheet and it's sort of really what
martin was talking about as well
so first of all you know you need a good
idea of what your outgoings and expenses
are
and if any of them are likely to change
so for example are you supporting a
child or a grandchild now
that perhaps you won't be in the future
or what sort of income
are you likely to need over time and
again this can easily vary
so there will be probably higher costs
in early retirement when hopefully
you know everyone can travel again and
you can spend some time in theaters and
restaurants and so on
then potentially costs are lower for a
while until they rise again
to cater for possible ill health later
you know much later on
um towards the end of retirement once
you know
your potential cash flow needs you can
work out if the pot is likely to be
sufficient for them and there are a
number of variables
that will affect how long that pot might
last
or importantly what cash flows it can
support and this is where i like to talk
about
um what i call controlling the
controllables
so there are a number of things we can't
control
we can't control inflation for example
we can't control longevity
and this is an interesting one because
people always
underestimate how long they're going to
live when they're thinking about how
long their pot needs to last
average life expectancy is now 87
there's a 25
chance of reaching 94 and a 5 chance of
reaching 100
but if i could count on you know on one
hand the number of people who think
that they're going to make it beyond 85
you know
i probably wouldn't use up with my
fingers it's unbelievable
now the nice thing is though that we can
model to see the impact of both of these
things for example longevity
and inflation we can also think about
market returns now we can't control
market returns
but there are areas that as investors we
we can control firstly you can influence
your own market exposure by actually
being diversified and staying invested
very importantly
you can also make sure that you make use
of all the tax breaks that the
government
gives you so obviously the main ones are
pensions and isis
martin alluded to them earlier and done
in the right way these could build into
very substantial
tax efficient pots over time for you and
the rest of the family
then lastly and really importantly you
can control costs or at a minimum you
can know
precisely how much you're being charged
and that might actually
make the largest difference to the size
of your retirement port
and it's critical to understand i'm
often
really amazed by clients who tell me
that an additional one
in fees doesn't seem that much the
reality is so different i mean
one percent excess in fees amounts to 14
percent of your capital over
10 years and since we're talking about
retirement we know that this is probably
a multi-decade
topic so if you take an example of a
million pounds
that would be 140 000 pounds paid away
in unnecessary fees over 10 years
and you could take off the naught or you
could double the amount but you get the
overall idea
fees are really instrumental to
long-term financial health
um so we use tools to help factor in
these different
controllable and uncontrollable aspects
so clients can see whether their
retirement assets
will be sufficient and it's a great way
to see for example
what is the impact of inflation on your
pot or
the difference it makes if you draw more
or less from your pot over time
and if we can control the controllables
we can make much more informed
decisions and give ourselves the best
chance of preserving
those all-important pots and if there is
uncertainty overall for example about
whether the pot
is sufficient or how different aspects
may affect its long-term value
it might be worth delaying any drawdown
until you're comfortable that you know
what you have
and that it is sufficient for your needs
or really importantly if it isn't
then what could be done about it
um martin we've actually had quite a few
questions come through about inflation
and other external factors that could
affect people's savings and we'll come
on to that in a bit
but for now what do you make of the new
variables that have been brought on by
the pandemic specifically in the way
that that could be affecting
um the spreadsheet that charlotte was
speaking about when when people are
considering what they have to account
for as they go into retirement
well on the point of affordability
i mean i think he would start from the
position that
everyone can afford to retire it's just
a matter of how many sacrifices you'd
have to make
to do that i mean at the extreme if you
wanted to
live in a campervan and live on your
state pension as it were
it's a choice that's available to you so
it is
possible but it might be painful
to adjust the level of your living
expenses
quite quite radically according to where
you want to get to
what you don't want to be is stuck in a
in a middle position where
your expenses are high and if we do have
a bout of inflation your expenses are
getting higher
but you haven't arranged your finances
in such a way
as to be able to see forwards as far as
you can see
that you're going to be able to afford
uh the lifestyle that you want so you
just have to make
some some choices and at a certain point
you you have to do that very actively
it's no point no good
sitting on too many assets that are not
paying you an income
but that are costing you money to run
you know if you can't afford
to keep the polo team and the the chalet
in
chamonix well they've got to go you know
but you can adjust
down to a viable lifestyle
with the the income that you know you
have ahead i don't know whether that
quite
answers the question about variables did
you have a particular
variable in mind i'm sure we're coming
back to inflation
inflation is a serious is a serious
problem and serious risk
from a retirement point of view because
uh for many people the
income they look forward to in
retirement is is not inflation-proof
and their costs may well be rising but
we can discuss whether the
inflation is a a blip or a or a
permanent shift that's an economic
question no doubt kate you have a view
on that
we can certainly come back to that
martin do you think that job insecurity
is also affecting people right now um
especially in
um older worker groups um we've
spoken a lot throughout the pandemic
about young people being hit but the
over 55s have
taken quite a big hit in the job market
as well and of course the furlough
scheme is still in place but
unfortunately
we know that more people are going to
discover that their jobs no longer exist
as that furlough scheme is
whittled down into the autumn so that
could be another variable that
a lot of people will be thinking about
right now that they weren't really
considering
a year and a half ago
uh yes of course job insecurity is a
factor in this i think we don't need to
over egg that in a sense that
uh i think the job market is going to
come back pretty rapidly after
a peak of unemployment perhaps in the
third quarter of this year and that
unemployment will affect
much more uh younger people in lower
paid
jobs hospitality sector and others uh
than it will
the as it were professional middle
classes who've probably been able to
work
from home and so on but i think the
general context that we're
talking about tonight and charlotte and
i think both talking about the same
thing
is that to be well prepared for
retirement you need to become the
captain of your own
financial ship at some stage in the sort
of second half of your working life you
have to
go through that holistic framework
process
i described um and begin to set up the
structure
that's going to see you through into
your retirement and that
is increasingly disconnected from
whatever job
you might be doing now if you're lucky
whatever job you're doing now we'll have
some
pension rights attached to it
contributing
into a pension pot uh you know
or almost certainly in our defined
contribution form of pension pot
maybe you've already got a sip or a
personal pension arrangement maybe an
amalgamation
of pensions there are businesses that
will do that for you
but i think being independently
set up and aware of all these factors is
absolutely vital because jo
you know the job for life has gone as i
said earlier
well charlotte let's pick up on martin's
note of optimism
it looks now like we're just over 12
months on from a record stock market
crash
and things largely appear to be back to
normal so can we finally relax
well it's a crazy thought that we've
just lived through such an extraordinary
global event
and yet stock markets are either back
above or close to their levels
pre-pandemic
however i wouldn't suggest things are
back to normal we've had an enormous
amount of fiscal and monetary
support which has led to huge debt
burdens in countries like the uk and the
us
and there are very real concerns about
how this will be paid for will taxes
rise could there be hyperinflation
will there be increasing deglobalization
as a result of the pandemic
and of course how will all of this
affect portfolios however the question
you ask is whether we could finally
relax and i do think that investors
should put themselves in a position of
being able to be confident about their
long-term plans
even if maybe not always relaxed and
one simple way to think about this is
what i call the three-pot theory
um broadly speaking we all live with
three financial pots
we may not think we call it that but we
have a first port which is the liquid
port and that's where for example our
income comes in our salary
we might have dividend income maybe
rental income
and out of that pot go our daily living
expenses
and then at the other end of the
liquidity spectrum is port three which
is the
illiquid part and that's where in the uk
it
basically always starts with our home
and if we're lucky enough it may be
homes
or we may have bi-dilette portfolios or
there'll be other
areas of investments that we enjoy so it
might be private equity
or direct investments it could be
classic cars fine wines
and sometimes i call that the passion
pot in fact because that's the
area of investing that we tend to spend
time in and enjoy
and we forgive those assets if they may
be illiquid or have high friction costs
because
we enjoy them in the meantime and then
hopefully over the long term they also
produce
some decent returns now in the middle of
those boxes part two
and this is where we should be able to
drive
what what i call sleep well returns
getting back to this point about how
relaxed you can be
we should be able to find a way to have
the core of our investment strategy
um invested across a globally
diversified set of assets
and for it to be done in a way which is
low-cost
transparent um and and
um flexible and if we're able to do that
then we have a really nice balance
between those
three parts um and it feels to me as
though
if we can achieve a point where
investors
can relax by taking the heavy lifting
off them then
that's a fantastic thing to be able to
do and still be able to retain
a large degree of control and
transparency so i think it's
um there's no question we're living in a
time
when there's still a lot of uncertainty
but going back to this point that
investing happens over long periods i
think there's a nice way to be able to
kind of construct this idea of the three
parts work out which bits you do
yourself
versus which bits you have someone else
do for you and at the core
really try to deliver those sleep well
returns to get you
back in your armchair or wherever you
find relaxing most helpful
well speaking of control um martin given
that it's easier than ever
to invest for yourself is it not now a
bit old-fashioned or unnecessary to be
paying an expert to manage your money
no not necessarily it depends entirely
on your own temperament and
level of interest in investing i think
one thing i would say is even if you're
a very enthusiastic
private investor who likes to sit and
you know watch the market for
half a day you still need a sort of best
friend really
um dude there's a sort of old-fashioned
concept
of the family solicitor or or the sort
of man of business you know in in
kind of in a sort of goals worthy and
foresight saga sense somebody
who isn't you know your immediate family
who gives you
advice and particularly actually on tax
issues and inheritance issues that kind
of thing you need somebody else you do
need an
expert even if you want to do the the
fund management for yourself but then
next question is how
how what is your level of enthusiasm so
if you're really not that interested
at all and you're pretty low risk in
your
outlook frankly you might as well
entrust your money
to a reliable respectable wealth manager
don't expect dramatic performance you
probably best not to pick one who has a
very didactic
view you know that wants to put all your
money into gold or japan or
some other particularly strong idea you
want the diversified probably global
portfolio that
charlotte referred to and you shouldn't
expect it to do much more than
than track the indices but your money
isn't going
to be lost if you've got a slightly
higher level of interest you might for
example
start to build a portfolio of of good
investment
trust kind of investments which are
themselves diversified but you can pick
sectors you can pick parts of the world
and so on
and if you're really keen then you do it
yourself
but that means you have to watch the
market day by day or at least week by
week what you can't do is
is pick your portfolio in a blaze of
excitement
and then forget about it and then come
back to it later and find
it's all gone haywire if you see what i
mean so it depends very very much on
your temperament and your interest and
frankly um
if your interest is low to medium then
a good wealth manager will be worth will
be worth a modest fee and
on the subject of fees which charlotte
talked about that hole
um that whole area is much more
transparent now than it
than it used to be but you do need to
scrutinize carefully what fees you are
paying
well charlotte you were talking about um
some of the
unknowns and the uncertainties that
still loom
um given what we've seen with monetary
policy over the past
year if we are going to see resurgence
in inflation
how can savers protect their portfolios
yeah i mean there's a lot of talk about
inflation currently and
one of the key drivers for markets is
the inevitability of a pickup of
inflation in the u.s
where last month's figures show that in
april the market expected year-on-year
inflation to be 3.6
and it was actually 4.2 and in the uk
the most recent figures contributed to a
still significant change to one and a
half percent
and this is against the backdrop as we
said of significant monetary growth last
year which has led
to a much greater focus on inflationary
pressures and it will set the tone for
markets
to understand how expectations for
sustained inflationary pressure is being
priced we can look at different market
indicators
so for example the inflation swaps
market is pricing in slightly higher
prices than has been the case in recent
years
and this is true particularly in the us
and also the eurozone
while the uk position is a little bit
more stable at the moment nevertheless
we do need to think about
whether this is a discontinuous change
in the environment for inflation and if
it is
then actually some of the classic
inflation protection assets
such as inflation in government bonds
could already
start to be looking expensive
commodities are another asset class to
consider
in an inflationary environment and we
have seen robust increases across the
board
in energy precious metals and
agriculture
and we actually captured some of this
strong price growth by investing via
cyclical positions in commodities
um in march but commodity prices are
driven by many different factors and can
be highly speculative which is why we're
actually very careful not to hold
strategic positions in commodities
over time the inflationary pressures
have a more direct
impact on fixed income assets and
actually a number of people have written
in to ask about that and there are
parts of the bond market which have
already reflected some of that pressure
we still believe that fixed income does
have a home for certain
lower risk portfolios but it is an area
that we reduced our exposure to
in march and that we're watching very
carefully equity markets
on the other hand can be quite resilient
to inflation and performance has been
broadly stable
over the past couple of months despite
the fact they've been increasing
inflationary concerns
a key factor behind this resilience has
been the recent earnings season
in the us and europe and the u.s
earnings season in particular was very
strong
with many companies beating what were
already high analyst expectations
i think it is worth exercising in some
caution though looking at these numbers
because the investor relations teams
tend to be very good at managing
expectations for the market
but the numbers that they're reporting
are much higher than is normally the
case
for both the us and europe and i think
that leads on to
potentially the bigger challenge for
investors and
that is one evaluation the high
expectations of future performance
already being built into asset prices
particularly in the us
and for now we're happy that this
earnings growth will
be sustained but it is something that
we're monitoring
incredibly carefully since it's a lot
higher both versus other markets and
also compared to u.s history
and we expect that these high valuation
levels will continue
to dampen future returns within the
market over the longer term and that's
why
our expectations are actually reasonably
modest in terms of
how we think markets are going to
perform over the next few years
one last point is just to go back to the
fact that retirement is a long-term
event if that's what we can call it and
there are assets that investors can
introduce to their portfolios
to dampen the effects of inflation as we
discussed but it's worth remembering
that these periods
are relatively speaking quite often
short-lived
so while it's not yet clear how well
or if we'll avoid much higher inflation
inflation
and our own view by the way is that
we'll be moving to a higher but still
relatively low inflation environment as
a rule we can expect these periods to be
relatively brief in the context of an
investor's
overall retirement years
uh martin what do you what do you think
i'm not going to ask you to make a
direct prediction about what's going to
happen to the
headline rate of inflation but and given
that so many people are increasingly
concerned about
uh inflation rising what would your
advice be
to savers to protect their portfolios
um well is charlotte's run through
most of the of the the pointers on that
i'd add to that that
the property real property uh you know
even
uh buy to let flats might be a bit out
of out of
uh fashion as it were but real property
generally
has kept pace or done better than
inflation
uh for a long time um farmland woodland
you know that's a very green way to go
with your money uh
worth looking at in the commodity sector
sort of etf type products that would get
you into
you know precious metals commodities but
also
big blue chip mining companies um
right now uh would be the sort of thing
but
on the whole over over the long term
blue chip equities and property
basically will will stay up with
inflation
um i want to move on to the questions
coming in from our audience i can see
that we have
lots coming in this evening i have some
that have been pre-submitted just a
reminder if you would like to submit a
question to martin or charlotte or both
you can do so
through our website in the text box and
you can also email events at spectator
dot co dot uk uh but before i make the
switch
um martin let me ask this isn't a
question that
perhaps we would have asked um even just
a few years ago but i think
it's hard to ignore now um this topic of
cryptocurrencies
how should a sensible investor look at
something like bitcoin is there a role
for these cryptocurrencies to play in
the portfolio
well so uh in uh charlotte's three pots
i have a similar sort of
little diagram on my notes and in front
of me the
third fourth or fifth pot you know the
very last
part the one you absolutely just take a
wild
punt with is the one you might take a
bet
on crypto currencies don't for a single
moment now i know i disagree with
some spectator readers because they
corresponded with with me very
in a very agitated way on this subject
but i would regard
uh cryptocurrency as a gambling chip
uh a very short term um
thing to to go into it's been it was
going up and up and up it's crashed by
50 recently it's extremely volatile
no one really understands what the hell
it is uh
but it's a gambling chip and if you want
with the very last the last five percent
one percent of your
liquidity to have a punt on it well best
wishes
and have a go but don't in any sense
think of it as being a core asset
for your retirement plan darla do you
disagree
i i couldn't have put it better myself i
mean it's one of the reasons i
talk about port 3 as being the passion
port because you have to be pretty keen
on something
like a cryptocurrency to want to you
know risk some of
your money spent in speculating which i
think it can't be described as anything
else
on the other hand as as you were saying
before martin i mean there are
people many people who enjoy a bit of
investing and sort of
you know having a punt on something and
there's no reason why
cryptocurrency shouldn't be among those
things and some people will have
you know done very well out of taking
some of those positions but i
certainly wouldn't put any uh you know
significant amounts of money to work in
that area
and i mean if you compared it with
investing in fine wine
for example i mean buying wine is fun it
probably goes up over a long period of
time but there is a risk that you'll
just
drink the stuff and if there's nothing
left if you see what i mean
uh there's a similar risk that a
cryptocurrency may simply
evaporate in cyberspace and not be there
at all but let's not go into that
well our people you're getting more out
of the fine wine in that in that set of
circumstances um but
you both described it as a punt
charlotte let me ask you do you think
that
position could change in time if as
we're seeing cryptocurrencies become
more and more entwined in the mainstream
financial world
um i think it's it's something that
could happen
i think we're a long way off it
happening still
i mean the whole question around
blockchain which is you know what
bitcoin is about so trying to
take out the middleman take out the
banks and take out those
intermittent charges that we all suffer
from at the moment by going through
um the sort of more traditional routes
for sending money from a to b
i i think the idea behind it is
interesting
and over time i suspect it will become
more mainstream but it isn't something
that
you know i would make part of my sort of
core investing philosophy for now
um well i mentioned that inflation um
was coming through as a big topic in our
questions and i'm going to move to
questions now
another one has been about taxes and
potentially a tax rate that could be
coming down the line given how much
money we've spent and
how much we've increased that overall
debt figure in the uk since the pandemic
began and
ben has asked this evening is there a
danger of a wealth tax targeting homes
that are used for primary residents and
how might this affect
people's plans for retirement martin
uh i think there is a pretty slim
chance of um any form of direct
wealth tax so we do have a conservative
government conservative chancellor of
the exchequer he
he was clearly looking at raising
capital gains tax
rates and perhaps bringing them into
line with income tax rates which
wouldn't frankly be all that radical and
would raise a bit of money
and he even backed away from that but i
think it's pretty well unthinkable
um to bring in a direct wealth tax where
you're
you're taxed a certain percentage of the
value of your assets
whether you're selling them or not um
under a future labor government
who knows um in the states there is
vague talk about biden
taxing wealth but what that means is
higher income taxes and capital
gains taxes there in other places in
france and elsewhere there are the
beginnings of wealth tax systems but
it it's not part of our sort of
discourse and vocabulary
at the moment and so i i don't think
it's a real risk and on the whole
question of tax i mean i think that
there could
be some tax rises that do sting
the middle classes and the higher
earners and the people with the
better pension incomes that are coming
in that is true but as i said
earlier on if you have taken the fullest
advantage of all the
all the tax breaks that are available
for saving for retirement
then probably the advantages is on your
side
in any case uh charlotte as as martin
mentions the chancellor seems to have
rolled out wealth taxes so far but is
this something that
you would advise people to be thinking
about planning 10 20 years down the road
well it's really interesting i mean tax
is a question which does come up a lot
and obviously there's been a lot of
saber rattling on the topic
over the last few months um i would
agree
actually that it seems to me the
chancellor has more room for maneuver
than we might have thought
and there have been you know these
obviously seemingly obvious areas
of low hanging fruit for the chancellor
which you know one as martin was saying
is
equalizing cgt with income tax but the
truth is that many of the tax fixes that
are being discussed
would have a relatively meaningless
impact on the treasury shortfall
and would also alienate a large number
of people in the meantime
so i i expect there will be tax changes
at some stage maybe
gt i actually think there may be some
form of wealth tax
um for example although you know there's
plenty of time to think about what form
it would take
but one thing that's really important to
remember is that when changes are
brought
in it's almost never overnight so in
other words there's usually time to
digest whatever changes
are announced and then do something
about it
and then i mean one final thing i would
add on this topic from my side i'm
always amazed at how many people
allow the tax tail to wag the investment
dog so to speak
i mean a classic example of this is
where a position
with significant capital gains is held
in a family or is passed on between
generations
and there's such relaxed reluctance to
pay tax
that the positions are kept and they're
kept regardless of the fact that maybe
the stocks
don't offer strong growth potential
anymore
and the fact that cgt is actually still
relatively low at 20 percent
so in the end it's better to go about
your financial planning
in the broadest sense where tax is
clearly a consideration
but among other things it and it
shouldn't define everything we do and i
think it can cause us to make decisions
we might regret if it's the main driver
um charlotte we've had a question
through from um
edward who's asked how you would compare
the tax advantages of an isa
to a self-invested personal pension can
you give some insight um as to
where you think the best advantages lie
right now
yeah i mean both of these um tax
wrappers are great things to have i mean
the
um isis you're able to put in 20 000
pounds
per adult and now junior ices as well
has
the limit has been raised to 9 000
pounds
per child so for any anyone in the
family below 18. so
in fact for a family of you know several
people
in it you can every year put in what can
amount to a pretty significant
amount into the isa or junior isa
um wrapper just remembering that
anything you put into the junior i said
does
belong to your child um as and when
they're 18 so
and of course the same is true for any
money that you might put into a an adult
child's isa um the 20 000 pound limit
every year
um but you can put together really quite
nice
tax-free positions through isis the nice
thing with isis is that the returns
um accumulate tax-free and you can so
you
you've paid money on the tax that goes
into the rapper but there after
it's tax-free the difference with a sip
is that you accrue that over time and
you're actually putting in
untaxed money it's the government who
will gross up whatever amount you put
into it
to be to effectively be gross and then
it is taxed
when you take it out at whatever um your
particular
tax rate is at the time um
i think both if possible are very
important to contribute to
um and they both there are different
reasons for that i think one thing to
remember
about pensions in particular is that
they're a very useful
uh planning tool for inheritance tax
because they fall outside of your estate
from an inheritance tax perspective so
it's quite interesting for us actually
as we work with families who have
over time put together isis savings
they've put together pensions they've
accumulated pensions over time
and they've also got their sort of
taxable accounts what's quite
interesting is to then
think about how do you work with those
different
um sort of tax-free buckets if you like
and then and then the taxable bucket
in the context of how you work with that
in retirement because in
in fact the the um the the decisions you
make in terms of which of those ports
you draw from
first um will end up having quite a
significant impact potentially on how
much is
left um at the stage that you're no
longer there
and and and the tax consequences of
whatever's left
so pensions are a very important tool
when it comes to overall tax planning
and and in the meantime as i said i
would
always try to fill up my iso bucket as
well every year if that's possible
because
again there are very attractive tools
and the really nice thing with isis that
i didn't mention
is of course you can also take your
money out whenever you want so you do
lose that that tax-free element once you
take it out
but there's there's nothing to stop you
taking it out whenever you need it so
they're
very useful if you're trying to save up
money tax-free and then you say in five
years time you need it to put down a
deposit on a house for example
whereas your pension you can't access
until 55.
uh martin natasha asks what do you think
the balance is between those
wanting to work longer and those who are
needing to work longer
i suppose another way of putting that is
what is the right time to start
making these plans and thinking about
what you want your life to look like
when you reach
retirement because you don't want to get
to the point
where you almost feel as if this
decision about wanting to work or
needing to work is out of your hands
hmm uh very interesting question
i think
it's sort of intrinsic isn't it i think
people just know
uh you can't know when you're 30 or 40
how long you want to work for i don't
think you could say
conversation here i'm sure i never want
to retire
but only i think when you reach a
certain point
of maturity perhaps your your children
have
blown the nest finally that you know
they're no longer a
financial burden on you uh
your health may start to
change deteriorate in some way
things creep up on you probably in your
mid 50s onwards
you begin to see the choices ahead of
you but i think something will tell you
you know perhaps your spouse will tell
you perhaps your body will tell you
when the time to to retire is
is going to be but on the whole because
most of us nowadays don't do the kind of
hard physical work that
the many of our forebears would have
done uh
we are well cared for well medicated
um in lots of ways people's hearts keep
going and so on
so i think most most people are well
capable
physically and mentally of going on into
their late 60s perhaps into their 70s
and we see many many vigorous
people in the business world in the
political world who have absolutely no
intention of stopping
and um you know this this isn't a sort
of um
uh self-help prince harry style workshop
um but what i would say is it's a very
healthy thing
to keep working so if you can do
you know and if you don't want to work
to earn work to do something else work
for it
work for charity work for a project do
something
really active that you always wanted to
do i don't know if that answers the
question it's certainly not a
financial answer but i think nowadays we
have the great good fortune
that we can and largely physically we
are capable
of going on well past what used to be
thought of as normal retirement age
charlotte what are your thoughts on this
well i mean i i would agree with a lot
of what martin has just said and
i think um you know one of the
interesting things as well is that
technology
is very helpful in allowing us to work
in ways
that we might not have done before so i
mean just take a look at what's happened
over the course of the pandemic we've
all suddenly become much more used to
being able to do a huge amount from our
home office for example and that might
well mean that for people who had
thought they would retire because they
don't want to commute anymore and it's
getting quite tiring and
you know they'd like to see more of
their spouse or whatever it may be
actually if we can now work much better
from home
and you know the hours that we work as
well can maybe be
mixed up a bit more we might go out and
i don't know feed the chickens and then
get back to the desk a bit later
so i think the very fact that what work
even
means has um has been
changed so much and technology allows us
to be so much more adaptable
that i think it's actually a very um
exciting aspect to how we think about
approaching older age and how we want to
spend
our time and i quite like the fact that
it doesn't need to be anything like as
binary
as it has been before you know it isn't
a question of it's five days in the
office or or nothing
um the there are going to be far far
greater
um potential to be flexible and i think
that this may be particularly important
for women
actually um whether it's a question of
how they come back to the workforce
after having had children or if they're
for example having to think about taking
care of elderly
parents then there will be all sorts of
reasons why
there's an ability to stay involved in
work and be part of the workforce
whereas before that would have been
much more challenging so i think you
know it's really quite exciting to think
about
what might be possible in the years to
come
we've had quite a few questions through
um asking for some
practical advice uh christian says he's
58 years old
and he's wondering what the best balance
is for his pension fund looking at
equities bonds
cash gold etc what's the best balance
and specifically what's the best
long-term bet he asks martin what are
your thoughts
uh well i think the conventional
answer i i'm going to defer to charlotte
a bit on this one this is a bit
this is a bit technical for me but i
think the conventional
answer to that is as you move towards
actual retirement age wherever you set
that to be
you probably want to be more moving from
equities towards fixed income
in the makeup of your sort of core
portfolio
um that is actually going to secure your
um your future uh
i go back to my first answer really
which is to to create this framework in
which you know what all your assets are
and decide
which of them you want to keep in their
present form and which you might be able
to
change to a different form so i think if
you're at the point of retirement it's a
extraordinarily sensible thing to do to
look at your house and think
could i live in a smaller house if i
released
a quarter of a million pounds of equity
out of this house which is bigger than i
need to live in
that's a quarter of a million i could do
a lot of sensible
retirement planning things within the
financial
arena but really i want to defer to
charlotte on that question if i may
of course charlotte yes i mean
one thing i should say is that we're not
able to offer financial advice uh
per se on this paddle either martin or
myself but
um you know the question i think is 58
and
and that's actually very young in the
context of
how long a retirement might last so one
of the things that is definitely worth
making sure of is to make sure that
those retirement assets the retirement
port is invested
um there has typically been this idea
that
as you uh grow older and as you approach
retirement you would want your pot to be
more in fixed income assets
i would think about it a little bit
differently first of all
just remember that just because you
retire
it doesn't mean that all of a sudden
there's only now another five years for
those assets to last they need to last
probably another
30 years in the context of the question
of this evening so
i would say they need to remain invested
in again diversified as we've talked
about before in order to avoid
um you know specific idiosyncratic risks
so to remain invested in a globally
diversified portfolio of
principally equity assets um
and expect that that will be the case
over a reasonably long period until
you know approaching much later on in
retirement
the other thing that that we do which i
i see happen a lot and i really like
actually is to think about
what you're wanting from your pension
pot so for example
for some people they may be looking to
draw relatively early
and let's take again this the example of
someone in their late 50s
so we know that there's maybe a 30-year
period that that port is going to last
and we may also know that we want to
start drawing quite early on
what i would do in that situation is
actually split my pot
into a couple of different places and i
would have
one part of it invested in much lower
risk assets which are the
uh more likely to be fixed income
dominated
uh therefore less likely to be so
volatile and that be the pot
that i draw from over you know a defined
period let's call it
five years or ten years and allow the
balance of the assets
to be invested in a much more equity
oriented
uh set of investments and therefore
really allow it
to kind of earn the market and to make
more
significant inflation plus type returns
so that at the point you have used up
that first more conservative port you've
got
you know hopefully a bigger and enlarged
pot to work on
for later on in your retirement
and we've had um a great question come
through which
i suppose on the face of it is simple
but i think
i wouldn't even know where to begin
martin
what is the one big thing that somebody
can do to make the most difference to
their retirement age and i think by
difference here
the implication is um better more
fulfilling and probably more stable
to make a difference to their retirement
yeah what what what's the one action
whether that be forward planning or um
certain kinds of investment what what's
the one thing that somebody can do to
make their retirement age more
comfortable
well i think charlotte right at the
beginning
um talked about uncertainty
and living with uncertainty so a rather
boring answer to that but it's it's a
solid answer
is uh you have to be sure
that for the rest of your life there is
at least a
block of your assets that's producing
pensions
entitlements and so on that is producing
an income
that will allow you to live at a level
you can
be happy to live at uh if you
if you follow me so you have to adjust
your lifestyle
and arrange your finances say that
if you feel bigger you may be able to
put a number on it you may be able to
put a sort of physical description on it
the physical description may be i would
like to live the rest of my
life in a small cottage in the
countryside
and i'll be very happy growing my own
vegetables
and what i need is an income that will
fund that and i guess that income might
be let's say i don't know
30 000 pounds net of tax per year
ignoring inflation for the rest of my
life you may have higher aspirations
bigger things you want to do you may
want to put a bigger number on it but
you've got to do the sort of framework
exercise
that i described and you've got to put
in the low risk building block
that matches the sort of lower end of
your aspiration of how you want to live
that's not an exciting answer but that's
the best way i can describe
it well charlotte martin's given i think
a very solid answer of
finding certainty what would your answer
be
well um aside from you know
sticking it all in bitcoin on exactly
the right day and it's
tripling in value by the following day
assuming you can then
get out of it and sell it again uh which
obviously would be one way to ensure a
very
nice retirement um there's something
else like that
that to me is absolutely clear for that
question um martin mentioned earlier
that one thing you really can't do much
about is
is the markets and i absolutely agree
that across you know people managing
wealth
for people there is um fairly similar
results there are firm
fairly similar results in terms of what
the investment returns are and yet
people spend a lot of time worrying
about you know should it be this should
it be that
and ultimately um i think the the net
result is not that big
i'm going to go back to a point i made
earlier the single
biggest way to help ultimately what that
retirement pot looks like
is actually cost and you know it's
interesting i i brought up the example
of paying
one percent every year more than you
need to
if you think about how uh
so much we hate the idea of a wealth tax
and you think that that wealth
tax might be one percent a year on our
assets that sounds absolutely appalling
well you know the truth is lots of
people are spending
or paying one percent more on their
investment assets
than they should and that that is a
wealth tax but rather than it going to
the treasury it's going to
a wealth manager or an ifa so
the impact of spending too much in fees
is really important i can't
over emphasize it it's probably the
single
biggest um aspect that will you know
make
that difference to your retirement port
um we are almost out of time just a few
minutes left so i'm going to squeeze in
one last question
um from our watcher tonight um for
somebody who is on
a lower income what advice would you
give when it comes to
saving are there any tips charlotte that
you might have to make sure that that
person is able to put away
a bit more money to make sure that
they're going to be okay in retirement
yeah i think um this comes a little bit
down to this idea i talked about at the
start of a personal balance sheet so
if you're on a lower income um you know
to some extent there's not much you can
do if the income you're on
you need to use you know every every
last penny of it and
but i think for most people if they
think very carefully about what their
outgoings are
um and they think about where
potentially they need to tighten their
belts
but they they really start to think okay
how much can i put aside
every month and they start doing that as
early on as they can and then they make
sure
that that money which they're not
intending you know then to
to spend or to use they're intending for
that to build up for some time in the
future
that money they invest because one of
the things that we
all tend to do too often is we tend to
keep money in cash
so we think we're building up this nest
egg and in fact what we're doing
is we're building up a block of money
that in the end is just going to be
eroded by inflation
so for someone on a lower income
particularly if you can afford to put
some money or time
some money aside then do it um don't
leave it in cash
invest it and then think quite carefully
about
you know would it for example make sense
to do isis i mean it depends again on
how much tax you're paying but if you're
paying tax they do make sense
and then it's important to the extent
you you you do make those types of
investments
make sure you're not being charged to
make them
when it's not necessary so just going
back to the point about isis
you know it's pretty interesting some
groups
charge you to do an isa an isis simply a
tax free rapper
and you know it is it is free for people
to use and then you will end up
paying somebody for what goes into it
you know in terms of the actual
investments themselves
but i think you know to come back to the
question little
and often um is important and to make
sure that if
you possibly can you you know you invest
over that long term time frame and your
money will grow and it will
help to build up into something for you
for the future
martin last word to you any saving tips
well at all i'd say in addition to all
that very wise advice from charlotte is
uh early in life i think it's still
pretty sound as it was for my generation
but the first thing to try and do is
become a home owner
your home will always stand you in good
stead it will
it will beat inflation it will be there
to sell to cash in
to to to downsize when you need to
secondly
stakeholder pension um i did one of
these
you know 25 years ago i forgot
after a while that i was putting i think
240 pounds a month the government
grossed it up to 300
in the pension pot when it came through
it came through as a pension for life
that's roughly
240 pounds a month guess what but the
fact is
that equates to something like a 500
pound
a month advantage in cash flow terms i
stop saving i start
receiving the income that's a terribly
simple thing to do
isas are a very simple thing to do and
if you've got
that sort of money you'd be foolish not
to do
do as much of the icer allowance every
year as you can
so those those are simple building
blocks relatively early in life
anyway good luck to everyone with their
retirement planning would be my last
word
an excellent last word well that is uh 7
p.m
on the dot martin and charlotte thank
you so much for joining me and providing
your wonderful insights to our watchers
tonight
for our events securing your future
thank you for joining the spectator
those of you watching at home
and once again thank you to our sponsor
netwealth
have a wonderful evening
[Music]
you